well what about the Libertarian Party
can you tell us a little bit about what
it stands for Libertarian Party is based
on a firm principle of non-aggression we
all take a pledge when we join the party
that we will never initiate force
against somebody else that is you know a
pretty simple principle that everybody
should endorse it's a principle of what
makes civilization that is you respect
other people's life you respect other
people's property
thou shalt not steal and thou shalt not
murder it's it's that simple and most
everybody agrees to that and the next
question ought to be is well why it is
why should you be different than
Republican Democrats if they tend to
agree with that same principle well we
we believe it's such an important moral
principle that if we can't take somebody
else's property and we can't hurt
anybody or we can't intimidate anybody
or threaten the use force we don't think
the government can either but we see the
government as the initiator a force to
bring about social and economic changes
day in and day out I mean they they may
not come up to our front door with a gun
and occasionally they do but we know if
we don't deliver our money in our
records and do obediently what the
government wants in order to give up our
portion of our income through the
Internal Revenue Service the gun will be
quickly at our door and we will be in
prison so it's the threat and the
intimidation and therefore they're
transferring well something that we
can't do as individuals so we as
libertarians reject this whole idea of
forcible redistribution of wealth which
is the welfare state same way in
personal liberties we apply this
principle in the area of personal
liberties in although I might want you
and think you should leave a certain
lead a certain lifestyle because I think
it's good in light and law I've no right
to tell you what to do you know if you
want to live a certain way I disagree
that's that's tough you know that's your
your choosing
that's the individuals choice as long as
you don't hurt somebody else so the
person has the right to his own life and
his Liberty his own lifestyle as with
one special rule that your lifestyle the
individual's lifestyle can't hurt
somebody else so if you do things that I
disapprove of I as a libertarian
and I am tolerant and I accept that up
and to the point of no injury to anybody
else now I've talked libertarians or
listen to them review them on TV and
they're talking about government power
all the time and abuse of governmental
power but I also see some libertarians
not a whole lot of them a lot of them
also talk about corporate power as well
in other words they're talking about
power in general there seem to be two
types of libertarians no I don't I don't
find I think we have one type of
libertarian because we all accept that
the same principle I think it's more
easily found that you have several types
of Republicans and several types of
Democrat because they're interventionist
and they can intervene any way they want
but I think libertarians are pretty
consistent in certainly condemning the
power of government I haven't heard a
libertarian saying that we need more
government or they're not a libertarian
but on the corporate power I think where
the confusion might come is corporate
size if its gained by serving the
consumer is not necessarily evil so if
if you have 90 percent of the car
industry for some miraculous reason for
some unknown reason there's no imports
if you have 90 percent of it that
doesn't bother me as a libertarian if
you have the best car the best price and
the consumers are very happy now if you
own if you have 90 percent or 100
percent of a utility company and you're
gouging the customers and the customers
have no place else to go
we detest the corporate size we detest
corporate power when it's gained through
government power you know government
coercion if it's a contract the
military-industrial complex is a pretty
good example of how large industries
benefit by big government of course in
big banking big banks benefit by this
monetary system because they're sort of
in collusion with the Federal Reserve
System
so we detest that we detest bigness and
we detest corporate power when it's
gained through privilege from government
if corporations are large and there's
always free entry in a free market if
they're large because they serve the
consumer we don't worry too much about
that because we know the consumers
benefit
if they get to the point if they had a
hundred percent of an industry which is
not possible to free market but they'd
say just for instance if I owned a
percent and then they started to gouge
the people there would immediately be
competition that people you know there
has to be there always has to be free
entry and free competition but there's
nobody's ever figured out where there's
ever been a true monopoly in a
free-market system to all monopolies can
be traced to some form of government
protectionism well of course now we talk
about the government and corporations
but as you've set up at the top they're
all the same people the corporate
executives go to and from the government
they hold positions in the government
the people from the Trilateral
Commission and the Bilderbergers and all
they're all corporate people and they
have their relationships and interlocks
with the banks and with universities and
foundations and all that so to talk
about one so you're really talking about
one source of power instead of
corporation on one side and government
on the other because it's all one pot as
you say I think it's become one pot not
only that is you don't have any help by
say voting for a Democrat who may be a
little more critical of large
corporations but we know Democrats are
just as much in bed with big government
- I mean you take a michael dukakis for
instance do you think maybe Boston that
was a somewhat dependent on some
military contracts Kip O'Neal I mean
they're just as much it's all
demagoguery when it comes to these
political campaigns so either side
they're the same people control it and
you know Ronald Reagan spoke sharply
against the Trilateral Commission but he
was the first president to host the
Trilateral Commission in the White House
I mean that's how blatant it is it says
it's the same group of people that's why
you find no political action committee
no large corporation who supports
libertarians I voted while in Congress I
think the the districtís free-market set
of votes ever but I never got political
action committee money
but small businesspeople who want to
compete against big business they're
their free market people and they're
much more likely to be libertarians and
believe in the principles of free
enterprise but once the corporation get
real large and they're more interested
in paying a couple hundred thousand
dollars for a top lobbyist who knows the
system who can get a regulation that
exempts their corporation or gets their
contract in place and this this is the
way the system works so we reward the
lobbyists of the political action
committees much more so than we reward a
principle of freedom what about this
banking and currency committee and we've
had congressman Gonzalez on it was one
of your colleagues and he sees the world
very clearly and sees the power
structures of work and I'm sure you have
a clear picture of this also is this one
of the reasons you became a libertarian
instead of a Republican well it's
certainly one of the reasons why I got
involved in politics because I was very
fascinated with economics in particular
particularly monetary policy and if you
think about it money is pretty important
if you look at all transactions whether
you're buying something or selling your
services one-half of all economic
transaction is the monetary unit so if
somebody has control over the value of
the monetary unit they control every
transaction therefore if you have an
institution such as a government
ordained bank like a central bank like
our Federal Reserve if they have
absolute monopoly control over the value
of that currency they control everything
in economy it becomes a form of a
government regulated economy it doesn't
become socialism but the money obviously
is socialistic in that the government
controls it
so they increase the supply the value
goes down if they tighten the supply
interest rates go up so it's tremendous
economic power in the insiders those who
know what the policy is literally can
benefit they don't stuff their pockets
and line their pockets with cash that's
not the way it happens but those who are
in the inside and knowledgeable will
benefit because they know which
direction interest rates are going in
which way the economy
is going and if you look at the members
of the Federal Reserve you find out that
they don't ask people like me to be on
the Federal Reserve even though I've had
experience on studying the issue and
been on the bank committee they ask only
the people who are casually referred to
as the insiders those from Wall Street
and the banking industry the poll
Volkers and the alan greenspan's of the
world they're on the inside they know
how to deal with the establishment and
they get these positions and therefore
it is a tremendous amount of economic
power falls in the hands of what we call
the Open Market Committee the Federal
Open Market Committee they control from
day to day the supply money they've
become the legal conner fitters you know
if you and I had control of the printing
press we could do a lot of a lot of
things you know self-serving that's what
happens when the politicians create the
central bank they get that to control
the money now this control of the
central bank and the money goes on
regardless of which party is in power
right it never changes you know they
change a person here and there but it's
always the insiders it's always from the
same group so if you have a Republican
as president or the Democrats they're
going to get the same appointments
appointments never change then this can
be said about the Secretary of State the
Secretary of Defense and Secretary of
Treasury and in the federal reserve
board members they all come from the
same group and even though I guess
naively I was hopeful that the same
group of individuals would not have as
much power under on under Ronald Reagan
but you know I was there I witnessed it
and of course that led to my
disenchantment my disappointment enough
to the point where I just said I've had
enough and then I left the Republican
Party and joined the libertarian party
with the idea that you cannot trust
Republicans to be independent on the
system either although Ronald Reagan led
us to believe that he would be
independent